each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
my name is Andy bagel I'm a researcher
in the hip research group human
interactions of programming and I'd like
to introduce Beth Simon who was a
faculty member at University of
California San Diego and thankfully
funny she's faculty member but she has a
very interesting title alluded to in her
talk outline which is lecture with
potential security of employment and
there's a lot of history that goes into
that kind of title certainly from
professors who are very protective of
the word tenure so in any case Beth is
going to she's got a long history in
doing a lot of educational work with
kids linked with college students
learning to program and she has also
worked on something called classroom
presenter which is actually being used
to present her talk today which is kind
of emerged of powerpoint and tablet pc
so she's gonna be drawing on her on her
slides today and today she's going to be
talking to us about studies of
programmers and how they can be used to
inform training instruction and practice
so this thanks everyone thanks for
showing up and the coveted after lunch
time slot but don't worry I'm used to
teaching at this time so we'll try to do
some things to to not only portray how
much I'm interested in the subject that
are talking about but maybe even not get
you to give me your opinion on that we
might be able to utilize and doing these
sorts the sort of work so I'm going to
be talking about some studies of
programmers and particularly I'll be
coming out this right now from the
educator point of view that is i'll be
presenting some work that's been done
recently amongst a number of higher
educators around the world and our real
interest as educators and also as
researchers is trying to improve
instruction and training in computing
computer science those areas and as you
know stated here you know we see a lot
of that not only on the part of those
people trying to learn
in computing topics but I'm part those
people trying to teach them and this is
really what we'd want to see we're not
really out there to torture them we'd
like to have happy programmers and so
we're interested in trying to see how
this make how to make this transition to
take place um so I'd like to start off
with a brief definition the problem um
it is hard to teach computing
programming and software development
skills and I'm guessing that a number of
you not only agree with that statement
maybe even have some rationale about why
you think it's difficult so I wanted to
start with the you know an open question
that we could maybe discuss for a minute
or two why do we think teaching
programming and computing is difficult
from your own experience or from
observing others anybody have anything
they want to throw out there about why
they think it's about yeah huge class
sizes ok so maybe if we're talking about
the formal learning environment and
higher education we might have huge
class sizes possibility I've also taught
a beginning program class of size three
and I can't tell you what I don't think
it was any more any easier than teaching
140 just different anybody also if you
need memories yeah my experience I just
remember that you're learning concepts
the same time as syntax language grammar
and that kind of thing though it's
frustrating trying to look you know put
into practice what you learn you don't
necessarily have all the text rolls down
yeah definitely cut the fact that we are
this is a professional practices got
both Theory concepts and practice that
we we at least teach together usually
yeah um there's a really wide variety of
obviously people get it okay you have a
non-homogeneous class with its
particular case
so there's sort of a wide variety often
not only of prior experience which can
be one thing but even if you try to get
people the same experience of them to
class they're just some people seem to
get it faster another one quite even
know how to phrase that but it's just um
speed or ease of acquisition okay right
so might have to do with styles of
learning etc my teaching experience also
found that a lot of people don't have
the background or the skills and logical
rigorous thinking yeah anybody know that
in the United States there is no
required course anywhere in the K
through 12 called logic you can graduate
with a high school degree and not ever
have been officially taught logic or
logical thinking and in fact even at the
higher education level a lot of students
never take a discrete mathematics sort
of course where we tend to go over
issues of logic and it almost boggles
the mind sometimes yeah so I definitely
I think all of these are in fact issues
on that we've seen and in program yeah
it's all ties together but sustaining
interest yeah sustaining interest boy I
can really go there um I was banging my
head against the wall three weeks ago as
I realized I'd done nothing but work
with them for two weeks on the
difference between passing a parameter
that's a reference object versus you
know a primitive type and I'm like why
why and the first ten weeks of
instruction am i spending ten weeks on
this why aren't we solving cool problems
I think there's cultural issues to play
the computer people are dorks and poets
are cool and so I want to take a poetry
class I'm not a programming class
yeah that probably has a lot to do with
who we get into our classrooms but you
haven't even given me a chance to scare
them away yet there and and yet we're
going to get there yeah so there's a
difference between people who are so
used to just being passive mm-hmm about
things whereas computer first you have
to act look at it and try things mmhmm
yeah I mean certainly one of the things
you hear how'd you get plus they would
just play with the code right if they
could just log on the machine and play
around with some cook on the other hand
the grand majority of educators don't do
that in classroom either so why would
the students know to model that or what
even to model and doing that and we
don't do it for them and we certainly
don't show them the process by which we
learn things maybe alright cool awesome
well thanks for the input guys I do want
to ask you one very simple question and
if we had wonderful internet access you
can all vote with your laptops in any
way but but we'll just do it a quick
show of hands or maybe you know quick
discuss with your neighbor for ten
seconds in the world trust you with our
consensuses on so one of the ways we
could drill down on that very large
problem of it's very difficult to teach
programming is to ask ourselves first
off what's the average completion rate
of a first programming course in higher
education is it a ninety percent be
eighty percent see sixty percent D fifty
percent or e 40 percent so give you guys
10 seconds to discuss with your neighbor
and try to come up with an answer and
then we'll I'll let you know in it
first two weeks of like the massive drop
oh you can define it well so there isn't
okay who thinks they know what the right
answer is not sure in fact not sure is
the right answer we don't know there's
currently a survey that's going out to
the listserv of computer science
educators around the web asking people
to please fill in this form and tell us
for your institution for as many years
as you can give us this information I've
along I am the the beginning computing
instructor at a very large state
institution of somewhat high repute and
I can't get this data partially because
we don't know how to measure this I mean
this survey is actually gone into detail
they want to know you know how many
people originally enrolled how many
people were still there after week one
how many people made it to the final how
many people took the final how many
people pass what's your definition of
pass because this is a worldwide effort
you know it's really hard to define but
we haven't tried I mean and and this is
an issue the abstract of this talk said
you know we've had 40 mumble years of
computing instruction because computers
appeared 40 mumble ish years ago and we
are I like to think of we're not
realizing we could spend a little more
time rather than saying oh wow these
machines exist we have need to train
somebody to program them we could start
to actually critically think about how
we're teaching computing and we can
start with very simple things about how
effective are we being how do we want to
measure list let's set up some
guidelines etc so so what I'd like to
talk to you about today is to give you a
little bit of overview of some recent
very interesting work that's gone on in
studies of novice programmers and this
has come about because there have been
no
CS educators who've gotten together and
been like look we're really tired of
hearing about these papers that say well
at my institution this or at my
institution that or I seem to see this
and they got together and they did some
cross in multi-institutional studies and
some interesting things came out
specifically about novice programmers we
like to study novice programs for a
number of reasons one there's lots of
interesting issues that novices have
there's something that you end up
finding about about a discipline as a
whole by studying how people first
interact with it and secondly novice
across Sweden the United States various
place in the United States were fairly
similar words if you're starting a lot
students at the junior level there's
maybe a significant amount of difference
in how you teach that would have given
them different backgrounds at that point
so i'll talk about three seminal studies
that have captured the interest of the
cs education community in the last
couple of years i'm going to then pull
that all down into a brief interlude on
my theory about the power of qualitative
work and why we need to bring
qualitative work specifically at to the
study of computer science education at
this point and then talk to you briefly
about some work in progress that i'm
doing with various groups of people and
some proposed to work i'm hoping to do
here at microsoft so one of the seminal
beginning pieces of literature in recent
history in in the past four or five
years on that has almost led the way in
terms of describing how we want to study
novice programmers as educators was done
originally in what's called an itsy
working group it is he is one of the
computer science education practitioner
conferences it's particularly the one
that happens in Europe every year
there's an American one that's called 60
and it is he has this function that it
before the conference there's a two-day
period where you can propose a working
group and you can get a group of people
together and study something and then
they guarantee you will publications
those kind of things um let's see this
was the McCracken group and they were in
2001 and this is led by Mike McCracken
from Georgia Tech and they got for
instance
data from four institutions all in the
United States over two hundred sixteen
students hopefully I was some power of
numbers here they asked students to code
on a computer a basic calculator program
was either an RPM calculor an infix
calculator without precedence or an
unfixed calculator with preference or
precedence and the reason they had to do
this variety as they were doing
cross-institutional in different
institutions said I don't think my
students would have learned what would
be appropriate for that at the end of
their first year of study or this is
what would be appropriate for our
students so faculty we're deciding at
their institution based on what you've
learned in the first year this is a
reasonable programming assignment that
we would a suit what we would assume
that students who'd pass would be able
to do this okay so this work was seminal
it got the ball rolling they define
novice as a term that we will use in a
lot of later work which is students who
are currently taking a course where they
would learn how to program a calculator
program using stacks or cues okay and
this definition of populist has been key
in a lot of multi-institutional studies
now they had gotten these two hundred
sixteen students to do this cut together
in over two landmark days evaluated
these programs and graded them out of
110 points they gave 30 points if you
got if your code would compile and run
with no core dump so basic execution you
could get up 60 points for passing
various test cases and 20 up to 20
points for validation and style at this
point you should all be thinking so what
do I think the average is across 216
students take a brief moment anybody
come up with 22.9 yeah we're talking way
below doesn't compile okay moreover the
both the median and the mode were eight
okay this is after a year of programming
instruction when honestly we really you
know instructions really thought they
can program a calculator and you would
kind of hope so
this code yeah they might have in fact
they might have heard problem with that
does that mean now there's some caveats
I would need to send you the full paper
to read about this they only gave them
an hour and a half we didn't think that
was very appropriate yes I know you can
do it in five minutes but they did it on
a computer had access to whatever normal
environment they use okay but still
pretty something that could not compile
um just anecdotally we tend to observe
students and they don't like do
incremental compile they don't compile
every five minutes they're not always in
an always deliverable state they'll just
code forever and then and they probably
ran out of time okay um so that was a
very dismaying metric so they decided
they need to look at the data in some
other way so develop this and a
qualitative analysis called the degree
of closeness where five is a touchdown
for is close but something is missing
three is close but far away to is close
by even further away and one is not even
close and even when you try to be a
little nicer and be more general there
they had an average of a 2.3 they really
this studied again 216 people they did
not observe the students in doing this
they did sometimes occasionally sit
there or certain people basically
realize that all hell was breaking loose
and so they asked some students
afterwards what happened and you get
descriptions of things like I ran out of
time but there was very little meaning
that came out of this other than oh gosh
we all thought they couldn't program
after year but gosh now we really know
it and it was very depressing so a few
years later after people recovered on
another what is he working group was
proposed this will happen in Leeds we
suddenly decided we needed to name the
matter of the location not after the
person who ran it this was a larger
study involving 12 institutions seven
countries which was quite nice 556
students and we said well writing code
is very good but they're in study of you
know English or anything there's there's
a can you write something but there's
well can you read something and code
reading is an important skill we think
although upon reflection we're not sure
we teach it um so we gave students 12
multiple-choice questions
and basically asked them to be able to
read and trace code with a raise the
great thing about this study is that
included both some cheap data collection
which was 556 students taking a 12
question multiple choice test easy there
some people when gave it as part of
their final exam but then there was also
rich data collection in that 32 students
were asked to do so in a think-aloud
setting where they either took the exam
or immediately review the exam after
taking it and thought aloud well an
interviewer would prompt them with about
what they were doing and so you get some
answers there they're also encouraged to
write on the test which this was run by
an Australian so they call those
writings doodles and so we have both the
answers we have doodles 436 and we have
transcripts for I can't remember it's 32
or 36 what are the questions we're
looking at just a basic idea so here's
something again these are targeted at
novices people who would be in their
second semester say where they learn
staxyn and q's you know do this code
fragment we've got an array of bullion's
we have a couple of for loops the
question is what does the variable count
have so if you can execute code like a
computer can if you can follow the
structure you can answer this there are
also some harder questions at least they
can't ended up being harder well maybe
there was put this on two pages because
it didn't fit on one they would define
something an inversion in an array is
this and they would describe a new
concept and then they would say here's
some skeleton code that's intended to do
something count the number of a verte
inversions in an array and then there
would be something that would be missing
and they say which of these four loop
headers would appropriately complete the
code all right so the results students
couldn't write code can they read code
they did better so here is our graph of
the results this is their scores so
there were 12 multiple choice questions
you can see the number of students this
is a histogram of the scores received
okay on those things who some of the
students didn't answer all 12 so we have
a reduced data set here so students know
overall results are they can read code
than they can write code it's good they
do better on fixed code just tracing the
code not on skeleton code where they're
asked to fill in so they are to some
extent able to play the role of computer
which is an important skill especially
in debugging and things of that nature
on the other hand uh students didn't
produce are they any doodles okay they
didn't draw anything and we in fact then
asked educators to do the same 12
questions and we found that educators
write much more they make tables and
trace values of variables and they do
interesting things with their hands
where they keep track of where they're
executing in the code whereas um the
students who we saw very few doodles and
they also the students who did the think
aloud they didn't really have a coherent
description of how they were going
through the code they would make it
through sometimes but it almost seemed
miraculous lift they got there at the
end um and I was particularly involved
in a subgroup at that working group
where we went through the transcripts
and identified strategies that we saw
students using in tracing their code and
trying to get to an answer um and we use
a grounded theory based analysis where
we just read the transcripts and read
the transcripts and then three of us
discuss while I found these words this
looks like a strategy of student was
trying to use to get there and we found
19 different strategies that students
collectively used in reading code every
individual student used a large number
of strategies usually at least five more
like 10 okay um and unfortunately there
didn't seem to be any correlation and
use of strategy and success partially
because every student used a lot of
strategies but we would see them
previewing the code they kind of look
out and be like oh there's a for loop we
would see them pattern matching they
would point out oh this is a loop over
all the indices in array I've seen that
before and they would match it to
patterns that they were familiar with we
would see them walking through the code
a lot of times unsuccessfully they would
get lost in the middle because they try
to move too fast and abstract away and
be unsuccessful at doing that and they
failed in many many other ways
and walkthroughs they would frequently
start over that was a good strategy we
liked that one when they would get
confused so they would explicitly state
their starting over and they would pose
questions some of them which was also a
strategy with that was quite interesting
why did they switch strategies why did
they get stuck um we didn't know because
again even though it was some more
qualitatively based data the way we
chose to gather data was just do the
think aloud and then come and analyze it
later we didn't we didn't really get
there and work with them over and over
again in a way where we could ask the
students question and that then being I
think you know a disappointment they
came out from this work we just we still
didn't get a complete picture what they
were experiencing even though we're
asking them to think aloud and that end
up being disappointing alright a final
review study can students design code
all right um so a group of about 20
educators from around the world came
together the National Science Foundation
funded them to basically learn computer
science education research techniques
and they went out over the course of a
year and asked students at the same
novice level to produce a design for
super alarm clock and they were given a
design brief that described this alarm
clock that would be used by college
students in you know basically you know
if you got less than six hours of sleep
a night for some number of time an email
sent to your mother and you know there
was a red alert and a yellow alert and a
green alert about officer today so there
was a nice little document one page with
about twelve bullet points and then we
presented to students with paper blank
paper and pens and pencils and said
please produce a design they were given
the following criteria should be at
least two parts and not more than twelve
parts and it should be something that
someone else could use to write the code
and I will show you a few screenshots of
the variety of things that novice
students produce here's a nice design we
see some boxes we've got a database a
controller and alarm we have some
description of different things of the
controller of the warning filter a very
sync you know I don't really know what
the right design for this looks like but
this this is at least something into
resting here's another design a little
bit less description but we have
interaction between components we got
database interacting with other things
we have sub parts we have some
organization so maybe that's an
interesting design this was a very very
very common style of design especially
amongst novices we have a main method
all right that's a very important part
of the design you have to have a main
something that you start on you run the
clock program you do something we have
some if statements that are done in
English you know that's pretty good and
then we maybe we have some some sort of
you know breaking chunking up of the
thing with set alarm by alarm etc by the
way almost every design was multiple
pages I'm just showing you a
representative also a lot of stuff that
we had you know I mean we're seeing
comments in here we're using the
commenting structure in see all sorts of
things I mean we saw a lot of code and
then you'd occasionally see stuff like
this mm-hmm who knows but it's kind of
an interesting design right so we did
not put any we don't have any numbers
like forty percent of the designs were
right you don't want to try to assess
correctness of design if you just want
to see what they think design is um all
right overview what so what do we really
know from all the states how does this
work help us improve instruction or
training well we do have some real
documented non anecdotal
multi-institutional answers documenting
success or failure and that is nice
that's very appealing to the computer
science education community I we can
show these problems really exist they're
not just problems with my students or my
institution or anything like that these
are real problems out there but what
we're really lacking is any real
descriptive power or understanding of
the problems that students face and how
we could improve instruction based on
that okay so I really believe that at
this point in history in computing
education it's very important that we
spend some time doing qualitative
research
and we need some very thorough
qualitative studies which could be small
because we've now said that students
across the world tend to have similar
problems at least they they manifest
themselves similarly but we need some
in-depth studies which can give us the
important rich description that we're
going to need the get into the process
that the students are using in failing
or going about whatever it is we're ask
them to go about rather than just giving
us the result of what they come up with
we can ask questions interactively where
we can really try to find out and
understand how the student is
experiencing some phenomena how they're
experiencing the difficulties that are
having encoding how they're experiencing
how they should read a code and why they
might want to read code and I firmly
believe that we have to do this that if
we believe in the value of the
scientific process which a lot of us do
that it has some real use in society and
in helping us improve something or do
you know well let's just stick with
improve something in a rigorous way that
the first step of the scientific
hypothesis is to make observation and
while I stand in front of a large number
of students and teach multiple days a
week and you could say that I can make
some observations based on that there's
a lot of learning that does not happen
in the classroom especially in computer
science oh we have conceptual and
practical components and that if we want
to understand where the issues are in
the ring we have to observe and we have
to do some rigorous observation and we
can't rely on sociologists or you know
people with PhDs in education do that
because why would they care about
studying computer scientists okay well
maybe the National Science Foundation or
somebody would pay them to do so but
we're the ones that know about computing
concepts I mean how how is somebody who
has no background in computer science
really going to understand the real
difficulty students have with indexing
arrays you know I could work with them a
long time on that but we could do it
ourselves we know what these issues are
so so that's my motivation I'm so just
to let you know now we're going to move
along i'm going to show you with that
motivation about two pieces of work i
have in prague
that are both joint projects with groups
of about five six people on one is on
resources students bring to learning
computing one is on bug location
strategies that novices use in finding
bugs and then briefly talking about some
proposed work that I'm hoping to do here
in in the near future where we will move
a little bit away from the novice a
higher education student but to another
critical transition period which is what
happens when we shove them out the door
and into your world and they show up for
the first time in industry and what
critical skills do they seem to require
and what ones today perhaps not have
because we didn't teach them so first to
review studies very interested in
identifying what students can do before
we teach them computing and at a number
of institutions across the country there
are separate entry paths into computer
science at my institution if you answer
yes to the following question do you
have any prior compiled programming
language experience then you are placed
in one class if you answer anything else
like what's compiled or whatever you're
put in the class for the people with no
prior experience um so we can actually
get at this um there's been some
interesting work by a fellow named John
hammer and physics where he's he's
advocating that you have to understand
the conceptual background people come in
with people come into their higher
education physics class with a lot of
experience in the physical movements of
things in the real world but a lot of
times those conceptual understanding of
how things were in the real world don't
mesh exactly what the models that they
would be teaching in a beginning physics
class and he says you have to realize
you have to get people to realize you
have to understand what what people's
real world conceptions are and use those
and treat them tell them when to apply
the certain models in the contrived
world that they study in beginning
physics and I think we need to do the
same thing our students all have a lot
of experience with concepts in computer
science if you ask anyone on the street
how do you if you had a list of 10
numbers and you had to place them in
ascending sorted order
could tell you a way that they could do
that but we would didn't actually really
know that they could do that and so we
did a study on sorting where we
announced students on the very first day
of class to tell us in English sentences
how they would arrange a set of ten
numbers in a sending sorted order and
the good news is they can do it
sixty-nine percent of students in cs1
courses across about their probably
seven institutions in this study um can
describe something that is a correct
solution it reads like an algorithm that
we could follow and get to a correct
list of sordid numbers that's good they
can solve problems that are critical to
computer science before we teach them
any computing now we wonder why they
don't make it through our classes but
anyway fifty-seven percent of them could
even do it describe something that
worked in a general case not just for
ten numbers interestingly the majority
of them do not describe comparison of
numbers pick your favorite sorting
algorithm and you know selection sort
find the smallest number put it first
insertion sort merge sort you're always
comparing numbers students didn't
compare numbers they didn't say if this
number is less than that number or
something they actually described the
numbers as strings so happened that in
the first round really gave it all the
numbers were between the number 0 and
9999 so they said first you'd put all
four the one digit numbers together than
all the two-digit numbers together and
all the three digit numbers together and
then they told you how to sort within
that and they would say for the three
digit numbers first put all the numbers
that start with one first if any of if
more than one number starts with one
then you look at the second digit so
they did it form a bucket sort which is
in turn dove-like radix sort which they
have a really hard time learning two
years later they can never get it but
they do it naturally before we teach
them anything so they don't really see
numbers as numbers now obviously they
can switch to do that and I'll tell you
a bit about that a minute they also
always use the word until rather than
while and this has been this actually
validates research that has happened the
past the students favorite post-test
loops because it's natural in the real
world you tend to say
okay I'll do these sort of things and
then I'll keep doing that until
something happens but you describe what
it is you're going to do first and then
we saw a real variance and use of
conditionals or in the focus of their
explanation where they focused on
getting a number first where they
focused on breaking it into into groups
there was a lot of variance there so the
good results in the bad results of this
study on we also performed this study
with some non CF study we particularly
wanted to do some additional studies in
the future on concurrency and debugging
and things of that nature and we
wondered do we always have to get the
beginning programming students right
before they start to stay because that's
a really hard time to get them at
they've just come to the University it's
hard to reach them without boy if we can
study non study years of computer
science there's a whole bunches of them
on our campus unfortunately after giving
the same sorting question to 500
economics one students and then weeding
out all the people who had claimed they
had prior programming experience we
found that they produce statistically
significantly different answers in terms
of they were much less likely to produce
a correct solution on and and then a
number of other factors as well that I
can point you to in the paper so that
that was the I said that was bad for us
as researchers but it's actually good
for us as people interesting computer
science those people who are self
selecting to study computing are more
naturally able to express a correct
algorithmic solution to sorting before
we teach them so even though we think
they're not doing very well they're
doing better apparently than those
people choose not to take our course or
maybe they would be doing better all
right now here's the bad so then we
teach them for 10 weeks about Java we
didn't talk them sorting okay
particularly talked them selection sort
because of those students who did
produce a numerical types or a lot
selection was the most common
unfortunately after 10 weeks of
instruction we asked them do the exact
same problem described in English
sentences how they would range 10
numbers and say sending sorted order
they're more likely to produce a
numerical style sort almost universally
they use many fewer examples and many
fewer words in describing their so they
have become more succinctly a good thing
but they're way less
to produce a correct solution and in
fact so yes now it's termed this that's
Simon considered harmful because I in
fact taught them and I taught them
sorting and in the end they couldn't
sort anymore um but what you do see is
there they've learned a new level of
description they even though you say
described in English sentences they're
trying to give you a more precise answer
in terms of arrays and how you'd
implement on the computer and in doing
so they haven't they haven't quite
connected yet okay they have a very
fragile knowledge of their understanding
of algorithm to implementation on a
computer um but even this needed more
qualitative analysis yeah Andy did you
ever try to give the students their
original answers to see and they
understood them as good or give them
other people's answers from the front
week zero after they've taken a class
and see do you think that this is a
proper story so I I didn't ask the
question is this a proper sorting but I
did I actually selected a student answer
that was um selection sort and put it up
and said you guys new algorithms before
you got here and I asked them to read it
and I said now let's together translate
this into some code and then I realized
upon doing so luckily I realized on my
office the selection sort from one array
into a second array is a lot harder than
selection sort in place but we did in
fact cover that first you know the whole
problem you pick the smallest number and
you put it first now you've got to mark
out that number on the list and I think
that was all a very instructive process
for them because it gets specifically at
their their differences in conception
between real-world manipulation of data
and computer manipulation of data but I
didn't particularly get that that would
be kind of fun anyway yes what does
Leslie yeah that's true I'd need to go
look up the exact number so we went from
like a 69 to some one thing
significantly below 50 so 40 ish percent
but you could see that the thing is if
I'd been there with each of those
students and I said no no forget a rave
just tell me I think they still could
have done it and that's again where this
this was a lot still a quantitative
study in that we just send people do we
need more quality amounts
can if we if prompted could they express
a correct solution at a higher level I
got to think the answer would be us but
we that would be much harder to do I
cannot go out an interview you know 200
students yeah one of the things I think
people lack is ways to extract that they
were able to do this we treat it right
out of programming they can no longer
abstract they have to be done in two
codes yeah and even more frightening is
that I actually require my students to
do interviews on every homework
assignment where they have to explain
code to a TA so I've actually taught
them in some way or at least I've given
them points for being able to explain
code and it's something I'm continuing
to work on I work on more and more every
time because I think it's very important
process all right Bo go I got two more
days ago and no time so bulky location
strategies of novices this is the second
study that I'm is currently ongoing we
have not collected the data yet um but
there's a group of about eight educators
around the world we meet once a week
using voice over IP and talk about what
is really important to us which is
students lack of ability to debug
because as educators anecdotally we
believe that debugging or lack of
debugging skills is one of those things
that is critical to failure in first CS
course and in the first year or two of a
CS degree there are some students seem
to be able do it and some that don't and
in case you didn't know debugging is not
taught in any real curriculum that we
know of okay we have now proposed a
course but anyway your little small
programming problem and a large
percentage of don't even check don't
even look at their results to see if it
is even halfway reasonable yeah well
I've written it and it compiles so we're
done that's I mean that's that success
by many students by many students
definition uh there's a great paper um
that basically says my program could my
program works but it won't compile
that's a quote from a student they have
a very different definition of works
than we do on ok so our study is we
there are two parts there's actually
three parts to to debugging but there's
two parts to develop okis on that
novices frequent with pick first is
finding the bug and second is fixing the
bug about 20 years ago in fact exactly
20 years a in 1986 katzen Anderson had a
paper where they claimed that location
was the only difficult task for novices
in reading this paper we don't agree we
being this group of educators who've
been reading papers for a year now on
novice debugging and partially is
because they were working in a very
specific environment with a restricted
section of Lisp and all sorts of things
that didn't seem relevant to us today
and we don't think that we will find
that so our goal is we've asked to
reproduce the cats in Anderson study
using modern languages we're not going
to restrict yourself to any one language
or each again we're doing a
multi-institutional study will each
produce a similar protocol in whatever
language and environment of instruction
that we use and try to identify we're
going to have let's see don't have
details oh why to protocol we will do an
observed coding and debugging section so
we'll provide students one of five
problems any multi-institutional study
you have the problem that we all teach
differently so we're using a protocol
from another from a Perkins paper you
provide people with a set of problems
you let them choose one you say pick one
that's not too easy and one that's not
too hard and you let them select they
will be given 20 minutes to code we will
and ask to think aloud while doing so we
will be there and observe any bugging
and bug finding that goes on and then we
will after 20 minutes we'll stop them
and give them a buggy pre-prepared buggy
version of that code which we will be
developing using preliminary experiments
to determine common bugs that students
make in making these in trying to design
these codes and there'll be similar bugs
across all the five so that we can try
to get things there and we'll see what
they do we'll give them then 20 minutes
to try to debug this code that they've
just been working on
and follow that with a semi-structured
interview really trying to now get at
the qualitative when asked them we have
a set of questions we'll go through and
ask them first just say so how did it go
and to see if they you know oh it's
really hard or well it was easy and
we're like oh really you didn't do very
well um but just to get their perception
of what debugging is and whether it's
miserable fun or something um ask them
what if they had any strategies that
they use can they articulate in any
strategies will certainly utilize our
observation try to come up with
strategies that we saw but do they
identify strategies that they use ask
them how it differs from what they
normally do in doing homework which is
their only real you know practical
component of doing programming um do
they find the same make the same
mistakes over norgren how is debugging
your own code different from debugging
someone else's code these are thing the
kinds of things were interested in that
we hope to work with students on so the
last another interesting that you could
look for a paper on that we're getting
together to discuss the data in June so
in you know maybe about a year um last
study is a study that I'm very sight of
it hopefully we'll be able to carry out
here at Microsoft and then a couple
other various places in industry whereas
like to look at a key transition period
which isn't the beginning of learning to
programming but it's sort of what
happens once students move out into
industry and so I'm very interested in
knowing what software development skills
are employed in the first few months of
industrial practice and that may you
know seemed very natural to you guys but
you have to remember it's always
frightened to me as computer science
educators almost universally none of us
have ever worked in industry actually
programming and yet we prepare our
students in some reasonable way
supposedly to to be prepared to do that
so I'd like to don't take the chance to
come in and really try to observe these
sorts of things I'd like to find out
what skills beginning software
developers seem to have already
comfortably developed in that they're
able
to deploy those skills to make progress
in the first couple of months that they
are out working and what skills do they
seem to need to acquire on the job and
how easily do they acquire them on and
then my goal from that is to then sort
of realize and try to identify if
there's any way in it in higher
education I'm not saying it's going to
be easy that we could potentially teach
these missing or underdeveloped skills
within the confines of the undergraduate
curriculum so a protocol here might be
to still under development but
potentially again bizarre observed
beginning employees in some industry
situations using a very ethnic graphic
approach follow them around okay and
just observe them don't interfere as
much as possible but do some interviews
etc and do this sort of at the very
beginning and then maybe after a month
when they've had a little time to settle
in and see what's going on and then also
have them give us some personal reports
on how things have gone during that time
so I don't really want to conclude and
hopefully we'll have time to do a nice
full discussion here um but I really
believe that you know difficulty in the
training of developers or programmers
are you know whatever you want to really
call that is an area of critical study
and I'm a firm believer in the
scientific process and i would like to
use the the process of observation
hypothesis fermentation and then
experimentation to really draw this area
and do some critical work in it um we
have papers that we frequently call
Marco Polo papers which is I went out
into the classroom I saw something and
it didn't look good so I did this thing
and I changed it and they liked it um
that's not enough in solving this
problem ok we need to start with serious
observation an observation that goes at
a detailed level detail descriptive etc
so those are the ends of the comments
that I had prepared but again I would
like to draw people into a discussion
about interest you might have in in
education in higher education and
training and then also specifically in
industry
and any ideas you might have for the
studies that we're still developing so
thank you very much yeah so when our
group does qualitative researchers
research among developers here we don't
tend to sweat the observer effect too
much we don't worry about Hawthorne a
factor because you know the developers
were watching are so motivated by their
reputation on their team and how they're
going to be evaluated during that annual
process you know they could care less
about us right but it seems like with
students if you're going to do
qualitative research you have to be way
more careful about the effect of having
the professor sit behind you watching
what you knew yeah so can you talk a
little bit about that about how you
mitigate that right um it is a serious
issue and and it's complicated by the
fact that usually the faculty at any
given institution who are interested in
this type of work are the type of people
are teaching the beginning students
which means they're frequently already
in the professorial relationship with
students we try to make sure that in any
given time no one is interviewing
students that they are currently
teaching now at my institution even the
chances of me teaching somebody else
again not likely to happen and I
actually get a beneficial effect that in
my classroom I teach students the very
first term I talk a lot about my
interest in computer science education
research and I make it very clear to
them in the whole process of the course
that I just want to help them learn
better and therefore I actually get
people who are more likely to volunteer
for my studies and to speak with me very
frankly because I and decides to also do
with other things I do in the classroom
where I show them that errors are good
and they help us learn and we discuss
them so that they're not as worried
about speaking to be but it is an issue
especially at smaller institutions where
you're going to have the same professor
over and over again and we don't we
don't have any really good way around
that other than students volunteer for
studies we it's almost never certainly
in a qualitative study it would never be
a requirement in a class and we have
large human subjects requirements that
have a
sorts of details about determining when
students are in a stressful situation
offering them outs etc for making sure
that that doesn't go along but it's
difficult yeah a couple days ago in this
very room we had a expert on testing
further so the standardized tests at the
elementary level and i was thinking of
just comparing and contrasting where we
are you're talking about how you
actually would you know screw observer
improvement or something um and maybe
I'm thinking about something far more
mundane which is how would you just you
know do recruiting how do you do the
interview process how do you figure out
you know which of these and in some of
these areas the numbers are huge with
the number of candidates applying for
positions and you would think that it
audit I mean and I think that our
interview process is just not terribly
effective we aren't able to let alone
you're talking about how to measure
improvement I just like to know how to
how to measure differences um all right
so right and you would think that at
least at the undergraduate level the
numbers are big enough now that it ought
to be possible to build a calibrated
test that was actually predictive of
something um well yeah you know we have
final exams every term you know what is
that supposed to be we don't know that
the final exams are predictive of you
know that came in a future performance
let's imagine that what I'm trying to do
is to predict the review on some review
process in a decade right and could I
show that that I could develop some
testing could be measuring at anything
that where scores on this court lady the
butt of your negative way wait with
future performance right so I think the
first thing we have to do is run the
study to find out what are the skills
that you need well I don't know that you
need to do that
the calibrations done well possible but
with these shooting in the dark multiple
times to see if we did and you have to
wait 10 years each diamond why are you
have to wait 10 years but um the numbers
are so large we ought to be able to do
it some is right now I don't think we
have a clue what any dinners I agree but
I don't I don't think we have any better
idea a clue about what matters or even
how to write said test I mean let's talk
a bit you have you heard about the the
physics stuff it was very popular I
think about a year ago so ago you know
beginning physics faculty like oh yeah
at Stanford great over any school
Colorado etc we have these great
students that get a's on our tests you
know they're fabulous then they give
them a very simple test that say you
know two cars hit each other what's
going to happen okay they can apply
these wonderful equations and solve
other things but when you ask you a
simple test where any physicist goes
well yeah if you know this equation and
you can apply it then you would get this
answer on this sub and the students
failed senior of physics students failed
okay and this was a real wake-up call
the physics community that we're
teaching them to plug and chug and we
think that we're designing questions
that that therefore that you come up
with the answer at the end and x equals
whatever and therefore mentally to the
students that means this interpretation
of physical movement but physicists
recognize that but but but the students
down right in the end and moreover they
don't they don't even realize these two
interpretations clash and so there are
some people are changing radically their
style of physics instruction to try to
to bring those together and we so one of
the problems that we have here is that
is i would call programming anwar so
that is it i think it's a very different
skill to be able to work by yourself
than to work more programming large is
either large team or large code base not
frequently taught at the undergraduate
well there's that issue but you know as
you said we could perhaps you know just
give them experience with it and even if
we didn't know the right answers maybe
that would even be better though I mean
it would be at least one step in helping
people uh get up speed yeah we can yes I
i I'm just wondering about a kind of
responding cool because the question
that he raised about how do you actually
make a student comfortable in an
environment putting is providing or
watching them mm-hmm and the question
for you is how do you look at tools that
can be part of their development
environment that will get the data about
the compilations instead of the court
that they are working on all that kind
of stuff and you can actually reusing
both in class and in the lab away a
graduate student at the University of
Maryland Jamie Spock Oh recently
defended and as part of his thesis he
developed a plugin for Eclipse and so
for the past three years at the
University of Maryland every student in
every programming class since they all
use a clip whenever they hit save
there's been a CDF's commit done on
their code and so they have three years
of every save of every student studying
computing at the University of Maryland
and you don't even want to try to look
at that data set it's ugly um but at but
so and a similar fellow has done a
thesis at the University of Kent in
Canterbury with a similar development
environment they have there in my
particular that I think there is some
very interesting data you can get from
that but you do get overwhelmed and data
very quickly especially if you're doing
any sort of because once you've got a
tool what you're like hey let's have
everybody use it um and then you have to
try to figure out what is meaningful
there and you can end up with the same
quantitative qualitative problem that
we've had before and and Jamie and this
other student have have both expressed
to me that that you know I should be
very wary of going there my particular
groups that are working on projects
right now orange going to go the tool
building route one we don't have the
resources to build tools if there are
five moves on a project then we have
five development environments that are
you some students use Blue Jay which is
a version I think of the Eclipse IDE
that's developed for students some
students use Eclipse some people running
windows
some are having them log in the UNIX
machines some people are using VI some
people are using notepad some people are
you know typing you know Java Sea to
compile some people using C++ some
people using something else and so we
just have you know as many people as we
have we have as many different
development environments and if we
actually desired to come up with a tool
to study that it would take us we'd
never get the research done so we're
going with observation to do that in the
same way that some of your developers
don't mind being observed because
they're pretty you know they they want
to succeed we have students like that
too you know they come from somewhere
and so the students who respond to it to
an advertisement about wanting to be
part of a study generally have some
pretty big egos and they can handle it
and win the case when they don't we just
stop and we don't analyze that data so
if they self select and they're very
calm today yeah we did the wrong kind
yes that's in fact true yeah we
definitely have a self-selection problem
you have that call tape we do try to
target sometimes we can look at students
background and try to reach some see
students or some students at different
levels but it's it's a serious issue
it's a serious issue and so that's where
again I personally I'm ready to do a lot
of qualitative work I think the two
together tell the best story yeah so the
discussion you had about the physics
students not being able to actually
understand what happens when to build
parts at each other as opposed to the
equations cry seeing each other reminds
me of like Jay Leno party goes on the
streets of Santa Monica and athletes
really stupid questions about like you
know what was the war of 1812 yeah I
hope I'm always hoping there's a video
camera in your face effect on that one
but anyway yeah so you know obviously um
a student graduating computer science
might know how to write a for loop on
paper because they've done it like
sixteen thousand times but it might not
know like given a certain problem that
they should be writing for them
obviously a lot of time they reach
industry or by the time there have been
an industry a couple of years unless
there have been fired lots of times they
probably get it at that point so what do
you think are the magic bullets or if
there is one like what's the one of the
actual experiences that happen in
industry that connect the dots for these
people because obviously like we are
grabbing some people that do make it an
industry people right so I don't I
actually think we're not in nearly as
bad as scenarios the physics people are
and we could probably make some
inappropriate comments about why that
would be true but I think we do provide
we don't just tell our students you know
my homework problems are not you know
write a for loop that prints out all the
odd numbers written from 32 33 that
might be something we do together in
class or a laboratory assignment which
would build them up but the problems
that we give our even though they even a
beginning programming class you know is
right a class that will represent your
playlists in itunes okay so it is
applied and because we're a very
practical and applied field and I think
we we do work on that but but then there
are the creaky critical aspects that we
don't get anything at which are often
communication how to talk about your
code how to explain your code the simple
question what is this code do I actually
was involved in a study I didn't talk
about because we had this came out of
the multiple choice question study
people said we gave them our multiple
choice questions to UM some educators
and some of them said things like these
are evil questions nobody writes code
like that except people designing evil
tests because some of the code was
nonsensical and we would see instructors
as they were hand executing this code
struggling to find sense or meaning in
the code in some of this code was
nonsensical it was there to see if you
could you know catch trip ups and things
that you know starting indexing at one
or something like that and so we realize
you know well that's what that's
something all experts do is they look at
a piece of code and if you handle loop
to somebody they'll say hey this
produces the average of all the elements
in the array between index a and B
that's a natural way to describe what a
piece of code does and then
wave our friends looked at each other
and we said do you teach her students
that no I don't teach my students that
so I've been doing it I've taught it the
last two terms and I have that same
question given to students the first
term when I didn't teach it at all
second term or I taught it some and this
term where I knocked down drag them out
every day in class we did these
questions and I said the wrong answer is
there's a for loop that starts at one
and while I is less than blah do this
and inside the loop if this I said
that's the wrong answer the correct
answer is something that's no more than
two to three sentences and explains at a
higher level and succinctly what it does
and as soon as I get the final
statistics on the exams that I've graded
I will tell you that yes they're doing
much better i believe i've got at least
ninety percent of them now who are
stating things at a very high level
after 10 weeks of instruction so i
believe you can train them to do a boat
we're not necessarily doing so that's
just one thing one thing that we happen
to find out that all experts do the same
way what are the other things that
happen in industry that people need to
be able to do how do you get involved in
a large code base how do you find a
piece of information how do you
recognize what information you're
missing how do you these are the things
we need to find out what we do what we
need people to do and then we can figure
out if there's some common way people
tend to do it and then we'll try to see
if we can train them so something is a
little like what you the exercise you
have there in them take a code it's
pretty straightforward and add comments
to it it sort of required the code have
comments at some point what we take a
place the comments that I see are
actually i would say wordy in they
imprecisely statements of exactly what
the code does so comment might be before
four loop that this is a for loop thing
add the numbers up or something right um
and you know the for-loop describes that
far more precisely and insightful II
than that comment did candy yeah I mean
I personally would find that very
interesting and and the question is how
much can we convince the community that
comments are important that the
community of cs educators that right now
if you give ten percent of your homework
grade for having good comments how
critical can we be in that you know if
bad commenting as you described we
probably get full points for that how
important is it that we not do that how
do we tell them what good comments are
it's almost hard for them to understand
what good comes or not but we could work
on it right understanding what good
comments are right therefore they tend
to assume that more is better right well
I think they've been some studies
showing that people don't read comments
well especially to try to understand
bozo Eiffel right well that could be the
reason why because you want to take the
variation on comments if you have them
just right asserts to verify that the
code hasn't been broken by somebody has
changed it yeah that is to work out one
of the key inserted key variants that
you're supposed to preserve actually
alone well how about if we teach us
Earth's the concept of an invariant was
new to a deadly that I was doing I mean
he had never heard I'm not sure we've I
mean assert is mentioned one place and
the first 270 pages of the first book I
use but we don't require them to know
that it seems poorly placed to be doing
it maybe in the first ten weeks unless
we move to a test driven development
introduction which would be quite a nice
thing to do but you know where does that
fit in the curriculum why is software
engineering an elected class in the ACM
curriculum guidelines um you know why
isn't life software engineering a junior
or senior level class what we could go
on what we have to in some ways you guys
are moving target industry is a moving
target computer science that's clearly
one of our issues but how how can we
formalize and stay more closely
connected with what it is people really
into when do we stop just
the same things that we were taught I'm
sorry yeah yeah this is wondering what
your strategies going to be to the top
of this industry transition I need to
see what the data is first we need if I
don't know because I don't know what it
is that we were lacking in teaching them
I mean it comes of finding out what that
it oh I'm going to follow people around
will follow people around and watch them
and then we'll ask them to reflect on on
skills that they that they found useful
and hoping to get their job done and
skills that they had learned before that
seemed to help them get their job down
skills they found knew that wow oh I can
do this and get this that's the current
plan yeah Andy so um presumably if this
results in implications for teaching
presumably some teachers to 360 and is
he might actually read this and decide
oh I think I'm going to do this in my
classroom but 16 is here about a
thousand eleven hundred people who
actually show up at those conferences
out of the you know let's say it's like
at least 10,000 20,000 people who are
teaching computer science because most
of them are research faculty who don't
throw these things no computer science
faculty member very few that I've ever
heard of have ever been taught how to
teach so in it in addition to
understanding what to teach then isn't
there a education component for the
teachers themselves to figure out how to
do this properly like you said that
computer science educator to the ones
who have to solve this problem because
everybody else doesn't care right which
is why next year at your faculty summit
which I believe is going to be targeting
mostly junior faculty should have me
come in and I'll teach them how to teach
computer since it is important um-hmm
there's the basic issue of time and
where you know and what you're rewarded
for in the higher education structure um
there's the push for positions like mine
I have the stupid title of lecture with
potential security employment on the
other hand I am paid to study education
and because of my interest in it
and I teach all lower division classes
at our institution a very few regular
faculty who primarily do research would
teach any lower division class but my
faculty are interested in making sure
the students that reach them at the
junior level can actually explain to
them why their code doesn't work you
know rather than just coming in it
doesn't work so they would like us to
train them better and all the things
that you want and I think a number of
institutions especially large research
state institutions are interesting that
we impact a large number of the students
the people with the smaller institutions
who honestly frequently don't come to CC
are very focused around having the
students learn and they apply more
resources to it and I think they can get
away and I was one of them to you can
teach in in different ways that allow
those sorts of things to be taught and
they are all very very focused on
providing their students with the skills
they need to go on to industry they just
don't feel like they have the resources
to know what that is I think if we made
significant strides if I could say five
years from now if i could post five
studies and the way i did today about
what people need to know to do an in to
succeed in industry that there would be
huge funding from the National Science
Foundation and other people to have
dissemination efforts for that work I
would like to think so anyway but and
besides when microsoft says is important
it's amazing how many faculty listen
any other questions people have right
well thank you again I'll be sure to
stay around